from coast to coast Canada's forests are
burning producing a cloud of soot so
large it covers much of the North
American continent in British Columbia
Donny Creek is the second largest fire
in provincial history covering the
equivalent almost 450
000 football pitches and still growing
firefighters fear it could be Autumn
before the Flames are quenched
challenges that we're facing on this
Wildfire is just a large area that's
been impacted we've also been witnessing
significant fire behavior and growth and
that's mainly due to the volatile fuels
as well as the wind events that we've
been seeing recently
in New York the smoke blew in so quickly
that a time lapse shows the skyscrapers
of Manhattan almost disappearing in the
haze in just three hours
City particles now stretch from the
Rocky Mountains and the West all the way
over to the Eastern Seaboard and from
Arc to Canada down to the Caribbean the
highest concentrations cover millions of
square miles of Midwest Canada and the
highly populated region between Chicago
and New York the warm and dry spring in
Canada has produced extensive fuel for
the wildfires and the country's vast
forests as of June the 6th there were
437 active fires with 248 out of control
and the Canadian authorities say the
country is now on course for the worst
year for wildfires on record the 10-year
average shows that by the start of June
you can expect just over 1700 wildfires
this year there's been more than 2 100.
authorities are warning that breathing
in the Smoke could trigger health
problems particularly in the young and
old and people with heart or lung
diseases so we're recommending that
people cancel their outdoor activities
we know that some of the baseball games
have been canceled outdoor activities
from professional sports are canceled
and just plan your exercise even around
this you don't need to go out and run
tonight you don't need to go out and
take a walk you don't need to push the
baby in the stroller this is not a safe
time to do that I want to reiterate that
wildfires are a natural phenomenon but
climate change is making dry periods of
weather longer and more intense add in
Wind to Fan the flames and you can
understand why fires on this scale in
such remote areas will be so hard to
bring under control
Thomas More Sky News